in Breaking News BBC presenter Hugh
Edwards has been named by his wife as
the person facing allegations over
payments for sexually explicit images in
a statement sent on behalf of her
husband she said that the events of the
past week have taken a toll on his
mental well-being and that he's also
currently receiving inpatient hospital
treatment well let's bring in our
correspondent Paul Brennan he joins us
live now from London Paul I understand
this Revelation is coming after other
BBC hosts were calling for the presenter
to name himself
yes the BBC has been embroiled for the
past five days in a really very
difficult situation uh after allegations
were made in a tabloid newspaper the Sun
that one of their top presenters which
now transpires to be Hugh Edwards uh had
paid it alleged anyway thousands of
pounds to a young person
um who is now 20 years old for explicit
photographs now the Sun newspaper chose
not to name the BBC presenter last week
when it first ran those stories uh and
there has been an actual lack of fact in
in much of the of the speculation uh
surrounding that that said though Hugh
Edwards name was being mentioned very
early on on the internet on social media
and pressure was mounting
um for him to either announce himself
that he was the person involved or for
the BBC or the sun to name him well the
statement that has been issued in the
last hour puts some well tragic con
context on this uh whole episode his
wife has issued a statement saying that
she's issued a statement on his behalf
primarily out of concern for his mental
well-being and for the children he was
suffering from serious mental issues and
has suffered severe depression in recent
years he's now receiving inpatient
hospital care where he will stay for the
foreseeable future once well enough he
to do so he intends to respond to the
stories that have been published the
statement goes on in the circumstances
and given huge condition I would like to
ask that the privacy of the family and
everyone else caught up in these
upsetting events is respected I know the
Hue is deeply sorry that so many
colleagues have been impacted we hope
that this statement will bring that to
an end
and Paul I see though that the
Metropolitan Police is also saying that
there's no evidence that any kind of
criminal offense has been committed and
there has been some kind of an inquiry
that that's correct
one of the central innuendos about this
was that the contact between Hugh
Edwards and this person described as a
young person
um was said uh or suggested at least may
have started as as early as when this
person was 17 years old now exchanging
explicit sexual photographs uh below the
age of 18 is a criminal offense uh there
was no evidence put forward to to prove
that simply suggested uh by the Sun
newspaper and the police have now looked
at it they one police force looked at it
in April decided there was no
criminality involved now the
Metropolitan Police have taken a second
look they too have decided that there's
no criminal uh case involved um many
people might say look at the end of the
day this surely is a private tragedy
between two consenting adults or an
arrangement between two consenting
adults but it has had dramatic
repercussions on Hugh Edwards Mental
Health on the BBC's reputation and I
don't think the Sun comes out of it
scot-free either
Paul Brennan there with the latest for
us on that story from London thank you
Paul